don't be more proud of them i'm so happy
for these players and bud
it isn't every day that a coach gets the
chance to work with a two-time
mvp what has being with giannis attend
to kumpo
every day for the last several years how
has that shaped you
i'm so blessed to work with giannis
every day
he's a special human being he's an even
more amazing human being that he is a
player
i've learned so much from him his
leadership chris's leadership
chris and yada's together they've built
this i'm just glad i could be a part of
what chris and yadas have done
that's beautiful absolutely thank you
bud congratulations
[Music]
that's right mvp so now
for the presentation of the 2021
bill russell finals mvp award please
join me in welcoming back commissioner
silver
thank you i don't think there's much
doubt but he
played through adversity he played
through injury
no doubt given he was the two-time mvp
in the league this year's bill russell
finals mvp giannis artericum
[Applause]
[Music]
be honest when you resigned
here you said that you wanted to be a
part of building a championship culture
in milwaukee for years to come
what does it mean to you to make good on
that commitment in the city that drafted
you
it means a lot i want to thank milwaukee
for believing in me
you know thank my teammates man they
played hard every
every freaking game you know i trusted
this team i wanted to do it here in the
city i wanted to do it with this guy so
i'm happy i'm happy that we're able to
get it done
[Music]
[Applause]
it is a rarity giannis to be able to
play
eight years with a teammate let alone
win a championship together
in those eight years how would you
describe what chris middleton means to
you
chris you did it huh you [ __ ] did it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know i i'm happy i'm happy man
this guy this guy doesn't really know
how much he pushed me he pushed me every
day to be great
he pushes me every every day to be great
man and i'm happy that
i can step on the floor with this guy
and play every single meme with these
guys and the rest of the guys but please
especially
we've been together for eight years and
i'm happy that i was able to do it with
him
i'm happy that i was able to do this
team for milwaukee and how coach bhatt
say we got to do it again
i think i think they like that
[Applause]
giannis you've never been shy
that family is at the core of everything
you do and now you and two of your
brothers
are nba champions
hey i'm just
i'm just happy i'm happy that you know a
lot of people was making uh
jokes last year when kostas won his uh
championship with the lakers
and you know obviously uh and the dinner
table was awkward a little bit because
he had the ring before me
but now myth and that's happening so so
we're happy we [ __ ] had it
thank you giannis congratulations
chris middleton bring that trophy on up
here